let's take you through how the
relationship between William and Harry
has broken down over the last few years
the first reports often falling out
between the brothers emerged at the end
of 2018 a year later while on tour in
Africa Prince Harry validated the rumors
stating in a documentary interview that
he and his brother were on different
paths
a few months after that Revelation Harry
and Megan announced that they would be
stepping back from their duties as
senior Royals before going on to sign a
multi-million dollar deal with Netflix
later that year
in March 2021 the sussexes aired their
grievances in a tell-all interview with
Oprah Winfrey in which they claimed a
member of the royal family had made
racist remarks about their son
Prince William was the first Royal to
speak out against the interview
rejecting their claim that the royal
family is racist
however the brothers were United in July
for the unveiling of a memorial for
their mother Princess Diana's 60th
birthday
fast forward a year and Harry and
Megan's Netflix documentary aired
detailing the couple's unhappiness over
the last few years